[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now the
supreme court will begin
reviewing the affordable care act
lawsuit on november 10th that's tomorrow
here to tell us more is patrick castle
from the multi-care group patrick good
to see you again
good to see you again so first off give
us a brief summary of the lawsuit
essentially because of the individual
mandate went away
the government is now being challenged
by the texas courts that
this law is no longer constitutional
texas and in california is fighting
against it
the interesting thing is now that the
individual mandate is taken out it may
not necessarily be constitutional
and essentially they could do away with
the entire health care law
the thing that's really interesting
about this is that
now we have a transition in president
the same people who put forth the
affordable care act will be back to fix
it all over again
and the sad part is the premiums have
gone up 400 percent so we have to hope
that they realize they put together a
health care plan that's very expensive
and this year out of pockets are up to
eighty five hundred and fifty dollars
that is not affordable for the average
person so so you probably answer the
question there but how will the election
of joe biden
change this lawsuit well the lawsuit is
important they can't change the lawsuit
that law so it's going forth
just like the new law that passed about
transparency can't be changed
so essentially what's going to happen
now is you're going to see this go to
court
and probably around april maybe may
we'll get a decision
and when we hit that decision let's say
they get rid of it well that doesn't
mean people are going to lose their
insurance and there's going to be
immediately pre
pre-existing plans it probably won't
take place until 23
but between now and 2023 it'll allow
those people in leadership to come up
with a health plan that might work
the question is will they be able to
develop health plans that are more
affordable
and give us better provider access
nationally versus being
subjected to clark county only as well
as
give us plans with lower exposure
because now 8 500 and every year they're
going up
because next year in 22 it'll be 8 800.
so patrick about 30 seconds uh
the last question for you is is people
with pre-existing conditions
they have anything to worry about with
this lawsuit and everything that's
taking place
they didn't have anything to worry about
whether trump was president joe biden's
president or barack obama's president
again
no no no worries at all you'll
definitely have coverage that'll cover
pre-existing
i appreciate it patrick it's always
great uh talking with you and again real
quick you said
when we expect the ruling on this this
won't happen until
maybe april the earliest probably june
the latest so we have some time on this
thing
yes sir all right thank you so much
patrick we truly appreciate it the
multi-care group
clients are provided personalized
services and are there to maximize
your benefits when you need them call
them at 702-396-9449
mercedes